first of all congrats on the movie
i have a lot to talk to you about before
i get into the specifics of the film
i always like asking a few other quote
unquote questions
um so i am curious for each of you what
tv series would you love
to guest star on and what tv series
would you love to guest direct
i just did it and i i'm so grateful but
i
miraculously received a call
asking me if i'd like to come on uh and
and
have a little bit in succession and i
love the show and i love the
god the the the the complexity of that
family and that world and how these
people just
dominate and destroy and control
all of our lives and um
[Music]
it is a is a fantastic is just a
fantastic group of
they're so talented from top to bottom i
mean the the the
show runners and the all the writers and
the
and the actors and so i just got to do
that
um and um
[Music]
i think it's going to be really fun i
think it's going to be really fun
and you know you'd be surprised how many
people say succession
as an answer so um have you thought
about playing the lottery today
um i should you know
i do i do step and [ __ ] i mean good and
bad
you know like really good and bad like
but uh you never know i i'm not great
i'm not a
i'm not a great gambler i think you know
but i do gamble it's voluntary taxation
man
yeah exactly paul what would you love to
guess direct
i mean i have a i have a real soft spot
for peaky blinders i think you know like
i remember going out and
hanging with adrian when he was doing
luca and and uh
i think that show was just so so
terrific um
i thought dark was amazing too i mean
that you know that's actually on my list
everyone's been telling me to watch that
and i haven't watched you gotta watch
dark
everyone said it um do you remember what
it was for each of you
that got you interested in wanting to do
what you do was it a performance was it
a movie was it
do you remember what that was since i
was a little kid i
i don't remember ever wanting to do
anything else i mean i think as soon as
my
you know family had a camcorder i sort
of commandeered it and
you know it started you know torturing
my friends
uh you know on video so
there's nothing just being being sort of
surrounded by
story and storytelling and and you know
probably cable television honestly you
know um since i was a little kid nothing
i ever wanted to do
other than that and i i've always
been an actor for better or for worse
and again i'm very
fortunate in this respect my mother is a
is a photographer a wonderful
photographer i don't know if you know
her working name is sylvia plahe
and she grew up uh i as i grew up she
was a photographer at the village voice
in new york
and had an assignment to photograph the
american academy of dramatic arts
and they had up
a youth program with uh you know
a drama program and um
as she was photographing it she had this
epiphany and nobody in my family is
is within the business or in the
industry and my mother is an artist
photographer my dad was a
public school teacher and you know
the concept of becoming an actor in
my neighborhood in queens is just so
beyond comprehension and it wasn't
uh it wasn't a career decision it was
just
she saw these kids and she's like that
is what you do
all day on your own and i you know i'd
come home and i didn't
imitate this that i saw or
act out or whatever hell i was doing and
she
uh witnessed that and
i i gave i thrived
i you know i just i was already
interested in magic
and i feel like that was a stepping
it was an entryway into performance and
understanding
creating a character and so to speak
because i would create a routine
and and i would
create an illusion
for adults and there was this powerful
moment as a small child
to captivate their attention
and mislead them and there was a
mischievous quality to that
and i think that is also what filmmaking
is
is it's a magic trick
and you have techniques
that are individual and
yours to to develop and then you
you reel people in and you
you tell that story and
um they don't need to know all the
complexity and
suffering of making that movie they just
need to know that
they respond to the characters on that
screen and the story
and um so i guess that it was
it was something that i loved and
and uh understood in a small capacity as
a child
i have a million other things i would
love to talk to you about before getting
into clean but
since we're limited on time let's just
jump right on in so for people that are
not familiar with the project i hate
asking the generic thing but
paul how have you been describing the
film to people
i mean i think of this movie as you know
about a man who is a very bad man
who is trying to be a good man and
what happens when you give a man like
that a good reason to be very bad again
you know the beast that comes out of him
you know and it is a beast you know
adrian is a he's a force of nature in
this movie
um that's how i described queen
whose idea i think it's a monte carlo i
could be wrong but whose idea was it
for uh for adrian for you to have is it
a monte carlo that you're driving
no it's a buick grand national which was
only made in in black and was the
fastest
car that general motors made in 1987
it's a v6 with a massive turbo
and it's my own personal car
and so i as
paul and i were were concocting all of
this i was
i was i i knew this man i've been
wanting to
tell a story of this nature for
well over a decade now and i didn't
quite know how to go about that and so
it was a real
um was a real
it was a new chapter in my life to be
able to find
paul and to find someone to collaborate
with
to help pull all of these ideas and
and and an amalgamation of all the
characters and people that
i have come across in my lifetime
growing up in new york
and you know i mean it's a dream it's a
dream
role for me um and uh you know it's a
it's a very complex protagonist
in an action thriller genre and as
you've seen many film
you know that it is challenging to find
something quite like this and
especially for an actor and um i'm
really
i feel really uh grateful that we were
able to to
bring all these elements together i
think people won't realize
that you start in the movie co-wrote it
you did the music i'm just curious if
you were also
bringing lunch to the crew and moving
lights on set
and what else because it seems like you
did everything
uh or it did a lot i
did bring lunch um oh quite a few times
i did a lot
i'm driven by things that i'm passionate
about
and i put everything i had into this
moment
it shows on on screen um there's
definitely a few
um violent moments in this film can you
guys sort of talk about the way you
wanted to depict
when your character you know is i don't
want to say unleashed but finally
you know besides walks down a bad path
i mean i always sort of thought of uh i
thought of it as sort of like a siren
call
you know clean as is is uh is a guy who
sort of
always staring into the abyss and he's
right on the edge and he's doing his
damn just to not get pulled into it but
he's sort of destined to be drawn back
in and so i i you know i think there's a
sort of
allure um you know uh
you know almost sort of uh he's almost
in in
in a sort of a recovery from his past um
and uh and it's sort of it keeps calling
to him he keeps doing the work and doing
the work to try to beat it to try to do
the right thing to try to be a good man
um until uh until
you know there's a there's a reason for
him to go back
it's a flood gate
he goes on a bender and he's just just
been
doing his best you know and and and
you know i think that's a really
relatable thing for for
all of us you know you really
hold it back and you you know
you just pray that you can maintain
and then unfortunately at some
some things in life are
are too difficult to to um
react in the way that you you have
worked towards and it's a it's a it's a
it is a work for him it is a it is a
it is all that he's consumed with is to
kind of make amends
for his past and to
um and to be good and to uh
you know build up the people around him
and uh but uh you know
it's a it's a violent world we do live
in a violent world and
and um you know
there are people that are
very powerful and and violent upon us
and sometimes you know the it is
it is it is very difficult to know what
to do with that
yeah well there's a uh
flare gun i believe and a screwdriver
sequence
that um i remember in this film vividly
those are my flare guns and screwdrivers
by the way
i'm not kidding but that actually brings
me to the by the way
those sequences are quite good but
obviously you guys had to make this on
on a budget you obviously had limited
time talk a little bit about maybe
what were some of the really big
challenges you had to overcome
to make this film well
if i may i mean we made this also in the
middle of winter
in upstate new york yeah you know and i
really wanted to make this movie in new
york
um you know i'm a new yorker it's a new
york story
i wanted to employ new yorkers to do
this i wanted to bring in all these
great people to conspire to make
something and that's why it's such a
blessing that we're bringing this to
tribeca in 2021
which is so new york and such an iconic
place for us to share this movie with
the world and
obviously my love of de niro as an actor
and
and i just you know it's very exciting
but you know we
we had all movies are rife with
challenge
we had a lot of challenges and um
you know that too was a meditation for
both paul and i
every day we had to face the challenges
i think the beauty of independent
filmmaking i'm sure paul would agree
is and i've made all kinds of movies
i've worked on
you know the biggest movie for universal
at the time with king
with peter jackson on king kong and i've
made the smallest movies
and you know uh
there are always obstacles no matter
what you what resources
you have at your disposal um the beauty
of
independent filmmaking is it's you and
your
guys you and your core team that have to
fix the problem
or you fall on your face and there's
nobody there to pick you up
and creatively what that does
for a filmmaker for a producer and for
an actor
is it requires everybody to give 110
at all times and you're burning the
candle at both ends
and what what comes of that aside from
depression and exhaustion and
fatigue after the fact is
magic when it when it works
it is the burning
and the panic and the
ferocity within everybody conspiring to
make
magic in every moment that you have
because you have no
you have no window and when there is an
a mistake or something doesn't work or
the crane doesn't operate or whatever
that that you're up against you then
have to
rein it in and figure out how are we
going to make this day
and how are we going to tell this story
and how are we going to connect to those
emotions
and and uh persevere
and you know so much of the storytelling
is influenced by that
and what you end up with is
something beautifully austere at times
and
sparse and what lives
is the emotion and and the
and the and the truth because
you you ultimately everything else is
ripped away
and all you can create is the truth in
that moment
and if you're lucky and if you and if
you don't have the goods to do it or you
fail
you don't you you can't deliver that and
and
paul is tenacious he's a tenacious human
being and as am i
and you know we just fought tooth and
nail to
bring this home and to make something
that we're proud to share with with
people
and to come from a place of honesty and
integrity
and again tell
a story in an action thriller genre
which i grew up adoring that is
has a protagonist who's so complex and
nuanced
and and and that is that's very exciting
for me
paul i'm i'm curious what do you think
it is about
anti-heroes that people love to watch
on screen they're honest i mean you know
we we've been inundated with
with heroes that are outside of our
grasp our whole lives you know um
and i think an anti-hero is a is a
is a is a relatable
it's a relatable figure i mean it's
someone who
um you know who has
real human failings and limitations
um you know it's a it's just it's a more
that's a more honest
um a more honest figure and i think
we very much embraced the anti-hero here
you know
very much those are the real heroes in
life it's the it's the guy that ends up
climbing the building to save a child
who's not a fireman who's not someone
who's
has a technique and is trained and he
sees somebody and he runs and and
doesn't even realize he did it and then
he does it
and those are those are the heroes you
know these are all the people that run
into
to save others in spite of their own
fear and obstacles that just
you know propelled forward that's
beautiful before i run out of time with
you guys um adrian if you don't mind i
just want to ask you an individual
question
because i am a big fan of andrew dominic
and i am i'm just curious if you could
talk a little bit about working on
blonde
um just because i'm curious about that
project andrew's amazing
um you know
blonde is andrew's clean wanting to make
this movie for
also well over a decade and um
it's a it's a remarkable film i mean
anadarmus is
just magnificent in the movie
i i i i was
awestruck um by her interpretation
and at times i felt like i was acting
with marilyn monroe
i'm a big fan of andrew's work and um
[Music]
you know he uh he's a wonderful
filmmaker
and um he uh
i consider him a a friend now and i i
i i i'm waiting
uh eagerly awaiting the the release of
that phone
oh as am i um i really mean it you guys
obviously uh
are good together so i hope that you are
making another project in the not so
distant future
um you know because uh you know i'll
watch it
just throwing that out there you guys
have a great day thank you so much
okay thank you